hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game from round one of the
feedahs.com grand swiss tournament
that's currently being played in riga
latvia uh you guys all uh very well know
the a certain pirate that originates
from there
it's a classical tournament and it
features some of the strongest players
in the world and of course the prizes
are great but the greatest prize of
course is that the top two finishers
will qualify for the feed a candidate's
tournament in the next cycle so as it's
classical the time format is 100 minutes
for the first 40 moves then 50 minutes
for 20 moves and then 15 minutes to the
end of the game with a 30 second
increment starting from move one so this
is the first game we're going to show
it's an incredible one a really just a
uh you know beautiful attacking game so
you guys are going to enjoy it and it
features none other than the neighbor of
sicilian uh so let's check it out the
fabiano faces maxine chigave
and he opens with e4 we have c5 the
sicilian defenses on the board knight to
f3 d6 and now d4 yeah so nothing out of
the ordinary here captures characters
knight to f6 knight to c3 uh and as
we announced the a6 uh chigab goes for
the night of sicilian uh we have h3 this
is the start of the atoms attack you
prepare g4 then g5 if possible e6 and
now the immediate g4 we have h6 stopping
g5 and now usually white will play
bishop g2 bishop to e3 other moves that
have been played here but fabi goes for
a3 so it's a sort of a waiting move but
also as you are expecting b5 uh it will
uh help you in the future is so you
don't have to worry about b4 right away
because you know that black is playing
this he wants the fiance of the bishop
on this long diagonal uh and so on uh so
here we have bishop to e7 and now only
now bishop to e3 knight to c6
challenging the knight here and usually
white will play some like queen to e2
here but uh fabi goes for rook to g1 and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so it's not a new
idea against the night of course you
want as much support as you can for this
g5 push in the future uh so knight's the
d7 you do not want the knight here to be
a target and now bishop to e2 this is
also a very very important move when you
play against the knight or
because you really need additional
support for that f3 square
if you develop the bishop let's say
somewhere to c4 and then your queen for
example to d2 nothing is guarding the f3
square and then imagine some like 95
knight f3 check with a monster fork here
so uh here we have g5 black prevents any
further expansion also stops f4 and now
queen to d2 and now of course uh black
shifts the knight over to e5 so now if
the bishop wasn't on e2 for example if
it was on c4 and you were playing blitz
or bullet and you played bishop to b3
just
knight f3 check with a monster fork here
uh so bishop e2 remember this when
playing against the night earth so here
we have castle's queen side and now b5
so black playing all the standard moves
nothing uh new here uh and um
uh
usually when you play a position like
this when you have either castles on
opposite sides of the board or you have
castle queen side your opponent has a
king in the center of the board you
really want to play the prophylactic
king to b1 move but here uh favi doesn't
he here he just plays h4 so here
it's just uh no reverse gear fabi and he
he's going all out in this game so
bishop to b7 you do not want to capture
here capturing here is extremely
dangerous because then f4 and what is
happening with this knight what can you
even play here if knight to c4 we can
just capture this and now let's say
knight c6 attack the queen the bishop
and once the queen moves so we pick up
the bishop uh we've eliminated well two
defenders of this spawn so not just
queen f2 we're going to pick up this
pawn and the black's position will fall
apart very very soon so after h4 bishop
to b7 black also wants to continue
development as quickly as possible uh h
captures on g5h captures and now rook to
h1 fabio would be very happy to trade
rooks here to get the other rook to h1
and then do some damage along the back
ranks so here rook the g8 adding another
defender here and fabi uh improves with
rook to h5 adding another attacker to
the g5 pawn for the moment it's very
well defended but also fabi just wants
to play rook d to h1 and then maybe
something like rook to h8 will also be a
possibility so rook to c8 another
standard night of move uh very often
black will even sacrifice the exchange
here by picking up this knight and then
weakening this e4 pawn uh fabi just
continues to rook d to h1 and now you
don't want to allow rook to h8 so bishop
to f6 regarding this h8 square and now
f3 yeah also a very important move in
the against the knight of you simply
guard your pawns here and then if
everything is uh you know
okay on the queen side you can focus on
your own attack uh and now black really
shouldn't waste any time he should play
something like knight to b6 strike in
the center with the d5 that's the way
you want to play here but here queen the
e7 was played and this gives fabi enough
time uh to
not just consulted but also start an
attack so here king to b1 he now goes
for this prophylactic move knight to c4
attacking the queen and the bishop again
you can always expect this when going
for this setup and playing the night of
fan you will have to give up your light
square bishop that's uh uh very well
known but it doesn't matter your
pawns are on light squares uh you don't
mind giving up the light square bishop
as long as you keep your dark square
bishop so rook captures on c4 and not b3
chasing the rogue back so you don't have
to worry about this constant pressure
here rook broke back to c8 and now fabi
could continue this game in a lot of
ways but he goes for the absolutely most
aggressive one and that is knight to d5
and again it's uh nothing new the the
knight sacrifice on d5 is very well
known against the night of also there
are some sacrifices on f5 against the
night of or
and it's uh
very different
depending on what position it is so the
as this is a completely new game the
knight has never been sacrificed in this
exact same position but the
theme is always pretty similar so here
the queen and bishop are attacked so you
have to be careful if you just move the
queen uh we simply capture the bishop
and now it doesn't matter for example
knight captures we're going to play
bishop captures and g5 put pressure on
the knight the night spin we're going to
play queen f4 white is completely
winning here so black uh unfortunately
or fortunately it depends on how you
look at it has to accept this knight so
e captures on d5 and now fabi plays
knight to f5 so he freed up the f5
square for his knight now attacking the
queen and the d6 pawn and the queen
should defend the d6 pawn because if
this falls with check then everything
will be hanging so queen to e6 and now
bishop captures and g5 so just nicely
recollecting the pawn here
and saying i'm very very happy with my
position here even though i'm down a
piece and now uh how do you continue
here well there are two really really
good ways for black to continue this
game and we're going to cover both of
them since this is a classical game we
have to check out everything so rook
captures and g5 is one of them this one
was not played in the game but it's
really really cool and i really want to
show it to you guys uh rook captures on
g5 and now
of course knight to e5
so what do you play here the thread is
knight captures on f3 attacking the rook
and the queen so we're going to play
rook g8 to check king d7 we're going to
pick up the rook here king captures and
now we're going to play g5 uh sort of uh
baiting black to go for knight captures
on f3 but there really isn't anything
better if you just move the bishop then
f4 is coming so you have to go for this
knight captures on f3 queen to f for now
and now even knight captures and g5 but
now we finally get this knight captures
and d6 check move in and you can't
really keep defending the bishop if you
touch the dark squares then you go uh
you know
on the queen's diagonal then we can just
play some like knight captures on f7
check open up on this uh discovery and
recollect
the piece here and we're just going to
be up material and winning so here
you're going to have to play something
like king d7 knight captures on v7 and
now uh you have this uh amazing thing
that uh the
e4 pawn is hanging and black can capture
it in many different ways but it doesn't
matter how you capture it you have to
capture it with the knight uh so knight
captures on e4 and then queen captures
an e4 yes the the entire variation is
just really really ugly it doesn't
matter if the queen captures or pawn
captures because knight to c5 chick can
pick up the queen on e6 or on e4 so it
doesn't really matter so let's say the
characters we're gonna play knight to c5
check king e7 we're gonna pick up the
queen king captures and now we get this
position where black is up upon but
white is up the exchange most likely a
draw
as once black consolidates here and
connects his pawns it's not going to be
easy for white to counter that
but this is one way to do it so after
this bishop to g5 move so rook captures
in g5 really really an exotic move uh uh
in the game chiga have played uh not
rook obviously bishop the c3 also a very
nice resource attacked the queen here uh
and now we have queen to h2 putting
pressure on the d6 pawn and only now
knight to e5 so how can fabi make
progress here he's down a piece uh and
it seems like black is defending very
well so fabi brings the rook to h6 puts
pressure on the queen here also more
pressure on this pawn and here is one
moment where black has to be really
really careful in the game rook the g6
was played and it makes sense uh you're
defending you want to trade off as many
pieces as possible but knight to g6 was
actually the correct move so you have to
give up the d6 pawn but it's uh such an
ugly move to make for example knight
captures here with check we're attacking
everything here and once the king moves
we're gonna capture on b7 but now king
to c6 traps the knight and we're gonna
win the knight back so this is how you
want to play this uh however rook the g6
that's not a g6 rook the g6 was played
in the game
and now fabi captures on g6 and you
can't capture with the pawn if you
capture with the pawn just knight g7
check picks up the queen so you have to
capture with the queen and now we have
queen to f4 by fabi uh defending his
bishop and also just you know
enjoying his position very much and it's
very very difficult to defend this for
black so
just for fun you're playing black here
what would you play here uh to defend
this position if at all possible while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on going for that
one move that we never want to play and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course pawn to f6 uh
it looks really stupid because you cut
off your defense of the of the d6 pawn
but that's exactly what you have to play
and now if white wants the
i have any advantage at all he has to go
for knight captures on d6 with check
king the d7 and now nothing is uh really
good here because if you capture the
rook uh that's really not a lot of fun
we're gonna capture the bishop on g5 and
the white pretty much lost all of the
attackers the knight here
is hanging the queen is being attacked
so white will not be able to make any
progress here uh
just one second
uh sorry about that really had to get
that one so after king to d7 uh knight
captures on c8 was
will not really be possible so bishop
captures on f6 will have to be played by
white and then unfortunately we have
this rook to f8 well unfortunately for
white and now pinning the bishop and now
the only way to again gain any advantage
here is rook to h6
and then we will just have a nice rook
captures on f6 queen captures an f6
queen captures an f6 rook captures on f6
and now we remove the bishop here from
harm's way bishop here and now we have
two bishops for a rook yes white is up
three pawns and it will not be easy to
stop them but this would give black the
absolute best fighting chance so this is
what you would have to go for
in order to save this game however after
this um
uh queen to f4 move uh f6 was not played
knight captures uh on f3 was played and
this allows fabi to really uh put a lot
of pressure because now after queen
captures on f3 you can't really capture
on g5 because if you capture on g5 then
knight captures on v6 check king to d7
and now we pick up the rook and rook is
defending the bishop on c3 so now the
bishop is hanging as well
and there's really no good move here you
have to play queen f6 to maybe guard the
bishop but white will very happily trade
here captures captures and now you
easily escape with the knight knight b6
checking the c6 and now even rook to h6
pinning the the bishop here and there's
no good move here captures we're going
to play rook captures and now uh well if
you go uh down the board and we pick up
this pawn and threaten the bishop so
you're never capturing this pawn and you
know other moves aren't all that much
better so here white would be completely
uh winning uh if uh queen captures on g5
was played so black tried d captures on
e4 uh and now we have queen to e3
defending our bishop and still asking
black what do you do rook to h8 is
coming we're gonna pick this up and then
the bishop will again be threatened so
bishop back to g7 by chi guyv and now we
have queen to a7 that's the good stuff
attacking the bishop and you can't
really move the bishop because then
queen to e7 is checkmate so queen
captures and g5 is played with queen
captures on b7 and attacking the rook
here now comes rook to d8 but now there
is one move that ends the game on the
spot so feel free to pause the video
here and win the game for fabi while i
give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding uh
any of the moves like rook to h5 queen
captures an e4 those are all very nice
moves but there is one move that uh you
know just uh says to black okay come on
resign man uh and this is exactly what
fabi played so congratulations to
everyone who found it and that move of
course is rook to h7 this is what fabi
played and he was in this position on
move 34 that maxim chi guy have resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here the bishop is attacked twice
so of course we're gonna capture and on
the next movie there are no more
defenders you can add to the g7 square
uh and of course if the bishop moves
anywhere let's say to f6 then it's the
simple queen captures an f7 checkmate so
of course the game did not continue
after rook the h7 chicago resigned and a
very nice victory for fabiana corwana
who not only gets his first victory in
the chess.com video grants with
a tournament but also reaches 2800 again
so it's like he never even
it's like he never even left so he he
you know dipped in below 2800 and then
he saw okay i don't really like it here
and then he just came back so it's like
that with fabi
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed that uh we're gonna check up on
some other games also do uh suggest any
if you have any of your uh favorites uh
i would like to thank oliver nicho the
hoodie guy the wind machine tom darrell
and michael kennedy for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feed
agreements with checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day